- [Voiceover] Ruby puts a dish of macaroni
and cheese into the refrigerator.
The dish was 80,
80 degrees Fahrenheit
when she put it in, and the inside
of the refrigerator was
40 degrees Fahrenheit.
The dish cooled quickly at first,
so this is gonna be
interesting, quickly at first,
then slowed as it
approached the temperature
inside the refrigerator, alright.
Which of the following graphs
in the mT-plane could best represent
the temperature, T, in degrees Fahrenheit,
"m" minutes after Ruby put
the dish in the refrigerator?
So mT-plane sounds very fancy,
but all they're saying is
is the horizontal axis,
that's our time axis, and it's
gonna be measured in minutes,
"m" for minutes.
And our vertical axis in this plane,
in this coordinate plane, is going to be
our temperature axis,
and it's measured in Fahrenheit degrees.
So let's see what they're saying.
So the dish started at 80,
at 80 degrees,
at 80 degrees Fahrenheit.
So at zero minutes, right when
she put it into the fridge,
it should be 80 degrees.
So this one right over here,
this one is indeed at 80 degrees.
This graph right over here,
this is starting at zero degrees.
Not at, it needs to start at 80 degrees
if we're gonna model
what actually happened.
So this, we can rule
that one out immediately.
Then when you look at these choices,
this one starting at 40 degrees.
Once again, not what we need.
We need it to start at 80
degrees at zero minutes.
So we'll rule that one out.
This one also starts at 80 degrees.
Now let's think about the shape
of what the curve should be.
They say
the dish cooled quickly
at first then slowed,
then slowed as it
approached the temperature
inside the refrigerator.
Now, does this graph describe that?
It starts, before it
was in the refrigerator
it was at 80 degrees,
or right when they put
it in the refrigerator
it's at 80 degrees.
And then it starts, its
temperature declines quickly
at first, but then the rate of decline
slows as it approaches the
temperature inside of the fridge,
that 40 degrees, and that seems like that
this is what's happening.
The slope is become,
it starts out quite negative,
but it becomes less and
less and less negative
as we get closer and closer
to the 40 degrees Fahrenheit.
This one over here,
after some number of minutes
we do end up at this
40 degrees Fahrenheit,
but the rate of decline is
constant the entire time.
This is a line, this is describing
a constant rate of decline.
But what they described is
a changing rate of decline.
The dish cooled quickly at first,
so that would be a steep decline,
cooled quickly at first,
then slowed as it
approached the temperature
inside the refrigerator.
So the decline slows,
it becomes less negative
as we approach the temperature
of the refrigerator.
So you have this. . . .
this change in the rate
of temperature change
and so you are going to . . .
or at least I would,
pick this one right over here.
This one right over here
describes a constant rate,
which is not what was
described in the question.